that report from DWS Melanie Kura dibala
and she is covering the historic
election for us in Zimbabwe she's in
Harare and joins us hi Melanie good to
see you
where are you what's happening right now
hiya Sumi I've been her are at one of
the polling stations on this very
significant day for Zimbabwe the queues
behind me a massive people have started
to queue at four o'clock this morning
just to be able to put that cross next
to that candidate that they are voting
for today they're hoping it's gonna be a
free and transparent election and in
order for that to really happen in order
to everything to run smoothly I'm here
joined by Alma Brock German politician
and the head of the European Union
observer mission here in Zimbabwe Emma
Brock thank you so much for speaking to
us can you tell us a bit more about your
work what are you monitoring for
specifically no we have monitored the
whole procedure our people on this
started to be underground and beginning
of June already we have increased that
today we have 140 people on the ground
we will visit around 700 to 900 polling
stations or close to 10% of all the
polling station in this country and we
cooperate with other international and
national observer group stew have a
broad picture we have to see that the
preparation was much freer the
atmosphere than in the past
so that is a big of progress but there's
no cheating we do not know because good
has happened with the printing of the
ballot sheets or a voter's list between
printing and today are the same he has a
certain doubts because of the history
because of the cheating by the present
government of the opposition so it's
your assessment that it's not really
fair we do not know I said we do not
know it has to be checked
is every party has observers in the
polling stations and we self ask our
question have a look into that then we
will find out whether these
possibilities of betrayal are true or
not true they're considerably true only
partly true so that to make up to the
final estimation this will be not a
perfect election as we can see it in
most of European countries but it might
be a big big leap progress so that we
can say under these conditions we have
to see that the symbol goes in the right
direction but tomorrow we will know more
tomorrow you will know more you've said
that there are so many observers around
the country still they really can't be
everywhere is it really fair to say that
you can actually access that there's
will be a fair election or will it be
difficult look nothing is to see 100%
the elections will mean not 100% free
but what is hundred percent but I think
we have a clear overview behind all
premises as European Union since weeks
we know the people will look into the
stations and prove that and and check
that and we will cooperate with forums
the churches the churches are a huge
amount of people from the churches here
and from abroad here and we will compare
notes as we do this African Union as we
do it with the American foundations and
others thank you so so much thank you
very much for taking the time thank you
bye
so as you've heard there will be
progress anyway we'll be checking if
it's really a fair and transparent
election we have a lot of observers here
in the country and DW is certainly gonna
keep you informed on what the observer
missions are going to be finding here
instead I'll give back to the studio and
Melanie you know just one quick question
to you what about after though we know
the theme international election
monitors are watching the about vote but
afterwards will the two biggest
political parties accept the results if
they lose
hello Sumi there's really the biggest
question still remaining will they
really accept the result and that is a
difficult question to answer when it
comes to the opposition party they have
been saying throughout the entire
campaign that this will not be a fair
process here and that different ballot
papers have been printed it's just not
as transparent as it should be and there
are big fears that they will not accept
the result if managua wins and then of
course we also have the military where
the question is will they stay behind
will they stay in their barracks
if camisa actually gets the presidency
or will they after having now secured
the power for just eight months with the
zanu-pf
really handed over to the opposition
party that remains to be seen
DW is Melanie credible reporting for us
from Zimbabwe thank you very much